there was nothing but joy in the Buble
family today as Michael received a star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame and that
is so wonderful to see especially after
the unimaginable scare of their little
boys battle with cancer and Michael
admitted to Nancy O'Dell
that experience has changed him forever
what my family and I have been through
be impossible for it not to love them
for it to have an effect on everything I
do when I what kind of outpouring of
love did you see you did you receive
there would be people on the street once
in a while that would just they would
never ask anything they would just say
that they were praying for us and it
meant a lot Buble put everything on hold
for two years when his oldest son Noah
was diagnosed with cancer the
five-year-old is now thankfully in
remission
I think people out there have no idea
how their compassion in their their love
and empathy their prayers for my family
and I had meant as much as it did and
this was a really in my way a way to be
able to say thank you he's giving back
in the form of a new album out now
titled love you could say things are
perfectly hectic he'll go on tours
starting in February Michael and his
wife Lois sauna also welcomed a third
child Vita nearly four months ago
how about knowing life being Big
Brothers how do they like that love it
the beautiful warm big brothers gentle
gentle with her not gentle with anything
they like to fight and they like
spider-man and I'm looking forward to
some quiet you know princess dinners
nothing like a daddy-daughter date and
Michael also told us his wife and the
kids won't be with him for the entire
tour but they will join him as much as
possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]